good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of our
2023 2024 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and Sciences the
UVA School of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has put a focus on
the use of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to the different
themes in biomedical and Health Sciences our theme
for this year is focused on building Partnerships
for generative generative AI training in biomedic
and clinical research where every Friday we will
enjoy uh uh talks from a range of leading thinkers
about the issues the promises the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with the emerging
uh challenges in AI based uh methods applied to
biomedical science data types um indeed we'd like
to make sure that we mention that the uh to our
folks that our 2023 2024 application cycle is open
and we encourage Junior faculty members working
in areas such as the development of generative
AI based methods applied to biomedical research
and those Junior faculty actively utilizing AI
in their biomedical teaching should consider
applying we believe this is an exciting and
engaging program bringing together AI platform
developers with University level Educators to
better understand the power the promise and
potential perils associated with the generative AI
explosion participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will leverage
seminars like this one as vital materials for our
culminating in-person manuscript and Grant
project development Workshop to be held at
the bajia beachfront Resort located in Sunny
San Diego California in June of 2024 today I
am delighted to welcome our speaker Dr Steven
Baek from the University of Virginia's School
of data science Dr baek is an associate professor
of data science um where he is an applied geometer
engineer data scientist with a keen interest in
geometric data analysis he applies computational
differential geometry computer vision and machine
learning to address problems in physics mechanical
engineering Material Science sports science and
medicine he has been a principal investigator
of various research projects funded by the
federal government and Industry sponsors
such as the National Science Foundation the
National Institutes of Health the Air Force
the Army NASA Department of Transportation and
Hyundai Motors amongst others in continuing with
our 2023 2024 biomedical data science seminar
series theme Steven's lecture today is entitled
can AI uncover the laws of physics by observing
apples falling from trees Stephen will tell us
about the moving Beyond mere pattern recognition
um that machines are now capable of extracting
new insights from hidden Trends and patterns and
generating lifelike images and coherent text and
making complex decision decisions in intricate
environments all these advances and U all this
progress is happening at an astonishing rate but
it begs the question of whether AI will eventually
attain the level of intelligence required to
delve into highly intellectual Pursuits like
comprehending the fundamental laws of physics
in this presentation Dr baek will highlight some
of the recent Frontiers in physics aware deep
learning and demonstrate their application in
solving complex mechanical engineering problems
ranging from designing composite materials to
predicting Quantum spin Dynamics and consider how
these might be appropriate for their subsequent
use in biom medicine as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you're watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2023 2024 biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged to submit
any questions they have um via the uh chat feature
in their YouTube sessions I will be synthesizing
these questions and asking them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that Stephen welcome we are very excited
to hear your presentation thank you so much Jack I
appreciate it uh that's a great introduction um
so I think everybody who is watching this video
um would know what this uh this picture up here
means uh this is a picture of Isaac Newton um and
this famous you know story about the discovery
of the gravity right so Newton was sitting in
uh under the tree and then there's you know all
of a sudden Apple you know fall on the ground uh
and then you know Newton was thinking you know
if the Apple falls down you know from the tree
while the moon you know stays up there what is
the governing physics um you know defining all
this uh you know phenomena in in in our world was
kind of the question that he Ponder and then you
know as a result of that he discovered the law
of uh you know the physical law governing the
the universe of gravitation which is the the
equation that you're seeing over here so as
a data scientist I have a similar question uh so
let's say you know we have a machine or a robot
OT or a computer algorithm and then we show an
apple falling from the tree and then we ask the
robot to uh figure out what the governing law uh
of that Apple falling from the tree would be uh
of course um computer algorithms are not that
smart so probably we're going to need a lot of
data so instead of just one apple you know falling
from a tree uh we're going to need like millions
of millions of apples falling from uh different
initial conditions uh but still the question is
given that there is enough data with uh machines
and you know machine learning algorithm be able
to figure out the governing Dynamics uh of an
apple uh falling down from the tree so that's
going to be the story that uh I'll be I'll be
telling today um and especially um you know
right now I'm not very active in the area of
biomedical uh application I'm mostly working on
uh physics problems and Material Science problems
but just to help the audience to you know connect
the dots between what I do versus uh what you know
you folks are potentially interested I I brought
some examples from uh other people's Publications
so this is not from my group's uh research but uh
one example of where this kind of physics could be
uh Incorporated and then you know machine learning
algorithms could potentially be able to understand
the Dynamics is the activities in brain where um
we basically have these electric signals and you
know activations um dynamically changing According
to some you know governing equation defining the
the activities of the brain so if we can collect
enough data uh of the brain functions then the
question is will machine learning algorithms be
able to discover that uh governing equation uh
defining the the brain activities of the human
brain or similarly uh the Dynamics of cells uh
so this example over here again is from other
people's research but this is a a cancer cell
bics and as you can see a lot of things are
moving around here so uh the algorithm that I I'm
going to present today is going to be mostly on
um things like fluid dynamics and you know uh
the traditional mechanics but I feel like you
know this kind of biological Behavior could
also be modeled using some similar physics
governing equations uh where the cell growth can
be represented using uh the diffusion phenomena
uh this is kind of analogous to the diffusion
phenomena in fluids uh the movements of the cell
is analogous to ection uh sometimes the cells
are you know newly created or divides or uh or
dies out those are kind of the reactive Dynamics
in in in fluids and again uh if a physics um if a
machine learning algorithm is able to figure out
you know fluid Dynamic properties and you know uh
the movement of fluids and U things like that then
the similar principle could also be you know uh
applicable to uh the analysis of biological cells
and here's another uh similar example where uh the
potential kind of intersection between uh what I'm
about to present and then uh the interest of the
audience so uh here's uh electrophysiology of the
the human heart and then you can see this um uh
the the electromagnetic field is uh evolving over
time and then uh this is actually an application
of um you know some some other group in Italy uh
where they applied uh machine learning algorithm
actually to model the the physic physics Dynamics
equation of the cardiac electr physiology so those
are kind of the potential directions where
uh my presentation May uh intersect with
your world so with that uh my name is Stephen
back I'm associate professor of data science I
am also a mechanical engineer by training so I I
hold a secondary appointment with the Department
of mechanical and aerospace engineering here
at the University of Virginia and uh today I'm
going to be presenting uh with the topic of AI
uncover the laws of physics by observing uh from
data so today since a lot of my work uh recently
has been focused on Material Science uh I'll be
using the material science example uh in this
presentation but hopefully um you know you'll
be able to connect this um This research with uh
the biomedical applications uh at the end of the
presentation so uh what you're seeing up here is a
material called hmx hmx is a part of an explosive
uh so this is a highly energetic material and
uh hmx um is basically used for propellants
and explosives uh in various military and civilian
applications the way it works is basically um when
uh a shock is applied to hmx the shock will induce
um the collapse of the hmx crystals and then the
microscopic structures over there and then as
those microscopic structures collapse due to the
shock they will release a huge chemical energy and
then if the energy released by The the crystals uh
this microscopic structures is large enough then
uh the chemical energy will turn into some high
temperature regions called hotspots which are the
blobs that you're seeing from this movie over here
and when there are sufficiently many hot spots
enough to you know um create a self-sustaining
combustion then you know the things will start to
blow off uh but on the other hand when we don't
have enough hot spots um with you know not enough
strength or densities then uh nothing is going to
happen and the the heat will just dissipate um
and you know uh that's kind of the Dynamics that
we're interested in over here so for many reasons
concerning the safety and the performance of these
energetic materials uh understanding the number
uh predicting the number of hot spots and then
how fast they will grow uh is actually a very
important question because uh if there are too
many hotpots um you know happening you know like
um evolving violently then that means the material
gets you know too sensitive and even for a you
know a small amount of shock uh things will you
know blow off whereas if there is not enough hot
spots created then you know when the the energy
needs to be delivered it will fail to deliver that
energy and then you know uh we're going to have an
issue over there so the adjusting the sensitivity
of the material is actually a very critical um
research question in this area and then a lot of
people are actually work you know using computer
simulations to see how these hotpots evolve uh
under different um you know shock input loading
uh conditions or you know based as a function of
different microscopic structures but the problem
is uh one simulation usually takes about a day uh
or more on a DOD supercomputer so this is kind of
a devastating challenge if you think about it
because uh if you're a person who's interested
in the relationship between the micr structural
design versus uh the hotspot Behavior then what
you would like to do is to create a lot of you
know uh microstructure specimen and then run
computational simulations and then from those
data you would you know like to see the trend
uh in terms of you know uh what are those micr
structural parameters that will determine the
number of hotspots created and and so on and so
forth but then if one simulation takes you know
such a long time then uh it's going to be you
know practically impossible to understand that
relationship so um my research um you know this
particular project started with this uh research
question that how can we approximate the governing
equation of the hotspot Dynamics as a function of
those micr structures so what we first did
was to um Define this generic form of uh uh
Dynamics equation so here uh what you're seeing
is uh first of all uh mu uh is the variable that
represent the morphology of uh the micro structure
and then X is basically our quantity of Interest
which in this case uh in our case a temperature
and pressure field uh is represented by uh the
vector X and what this equation tells us about is
the relation the the rate of change the Dynamics
of uh the temperature and the pressure change as
a function of the current temperature and current
pressure and the micr structure morphology now
uh the idea here is since the relationship a
is unknown um and we don't really know the
exact relationship between the temperature
uh Dynamics and the the microscopic structures
so uh the you know the only thing that we can
rely on is basically uh some statistical model uh
parameterized by the variable Theta over here in
particular uh we decided to use convolutional
neural network a type of a deep neural network
that a lot of people uh use to solve a variety
of different computer vision problems so um
in in some sense this is sort of a computer
vision problem because our variable x uh is
the temperature field and it's basically like a
movie um that you saw from this uh the previous
slide so uh we thought this would be a a nice and
interesting computer vision problem in some sense
so we decided to use convolutional NE Network
to to model the Dynamics and then like I said
uh earlier uh the the variable Theta here is the
model parameter defining the convolutional neural
network so uh in our case this is the unknown
that we're trying to uh trying to learn uh from
a data set and then the Epsilon over here uh is
the stochastic noise and the prediction here now
assuming that we can learn that relationship
uh as a parameter uh I mean as a parametric
function um of theta then uh we can predict the
future state of the temperature field and the
pressure field as an integral as a Time integral
of that Dynamics over here so the the dxdt gets
integrated from uh uh for a given time interval
uh and then um since we can model this dxdt using
convolutional neural network by integrating the
output of the uh the convolutional neural network
we should be able to uh make a prediction of the
the future state of the of the material system
is basically the idea now all of this idea uh
at the end of the day bowls down to this kind
of a neural network architecture where uh we have
the two main things over here so the first thing
is this purple box called the differentiator CNN
so that is essentially the um the the dxdt over
here uh or the the convolutional neural network
f that models the Dynamics dxdt so that's that's
our purple box uh in this diagram and what this
purple box does is to take the current temperature
and the pressure as an input alongside the
micr structure geometry uh as an input and
then makes a prediction of the dtdt the dxdt
uh the the rate of change of temperature the
rate of change of pressure as an output so that's
what what uh the differentiator CNN does and then
the integrator CNN uh is basically a uh datadriven
approximation of this integral operator over here
so by integrating the output of the differentiator
CNN we can predict the future state of the
temperature field and the pressure field so in
this diagram that's basically what we're doing
over here by taking this dxdt as an input along
alongside the current temperature and the current
pressure we make a prediction of the future
pre future temperature and the future pressure
after a Time stap delta T now what happens over
here is we then use the same differentiator CNN
recursively and then make a prediction of the the
the rate of change of temperature and the rate of
change of pressure again and then we integrate
that to predict the temperature and the pressure
in uh you know uh after a Time delta T again and
then by recur you know by repeatedly um applying
this differentiator and integrator uh we can uh
basically make a prediction of the Dynamics how
the temperature and the pressure uh of this
uh Hotpot Dynamics evolve over time and then
the training is basically uh just the L2 loss
or the mean square error between the predicted
temperature uh and the ground through temperature
uh as well as the the predicted pressure and
the ground through pressure and then those are
compared um literally pixel by pixel and then uh
the neural network uh so the both differentiator
CNN and the integrator CNN learns the neural
net parameters to uh to minimize the discrepancy
between the prediction and the ground through so
after training this algorithm uh we were able to
uh achieve a pretty decent um prediction result so
here what you're seeing is the prediction result
of this algorithm which by the way is called the
physics aware recurrent convolutions so uh or in
other words Park uh in short because uh here we
have a convolutional neural network architecture
that is uh recursively applied uh over time so
that's a recurrent convolutions and then this
is indeed a uh physically inspired uh neural
network architecture so the name uh physics aware
Now using this algorithm we can actually uh do a
pretty good job in predicting uh the temperature
dynamics of um you know different micr structure
specimens so for uh in this slide what you're
seeing is for this given micr structure specimen
uh this is the computation simulation result uh
from that expensive simulation which took you
know about a day on a supercomputer and then here
we see the prediction result of the deep learning
algorithm and then as you can see that uh the
the location of hotspots and then their growth
rates are uh are very similar to the to the
ground through and then there are some other
um you know material specimens uh with varying
size of crystals uh different orientations uh
different parties and you know things like that
and then as you can see the hotspot patterns are
all you know different according to the micr
structural geometry and then as you can see uh
the park algorithm was able to capture those you
know different locations and uh and everything
so quantitatively speaking uh uh we could see
that Park was able to uh capture the Hot Spot
Dynamics pretty well uh except for the fact that
it sort of underestimated the absolute value of
the temperature uh about 500 Kelvin uh but other
than that uh we could see a you know very good
agreement between the park predicted result and
then the the the ground through simulation now
you may think that well still this is you know
not perfectly accurate and then uh you know this
is not giving uh you know perfectly valid
representation of the uh the real physical
phenomena but considering the fact that the
traditional you know more accurate computer
simulation takes about a day on a high performance
Computing cluster versus Park requires less than
a second on a you know a regular laptop uh that
actually you know creates a huge difference and
at the end of the day you know simulations are
simulations so simulations also are not uh the
most accurate representation of the physical
world uh and then you know considering the the
the the tremendous gain in the computational
speed um you know we can we can say that uh
this park algorithm is actually quite beneficial
uh in terms of analyzing and you know predicting
the the hotspot temperature Dynamics in energetic
materials so this kind of you know leads to a a
disc about the vision that the the big picture
that we're uh kind of you know thinking of um
and where my group is currently heading towards
so um as a matter of fact we are using a lot of
deep learning algorithms to facilitate the process
of you know designing new functional materials and
Engineering material Properties by changing the
micr structures and things like that so um what
you're seeing here is this you know relationship
between the the morphometric characteristics of
the micr structure uh versus the Dynamics of
uh of that donation and as you can see uh in
this particular example we're comparing the
you know different sizes of uh hmx crystals
and as you can see for small crystals we get
to see a you know a lot more you know violent
and dynamic uh you know process compared to the
larger crystals and you know the Hope over here
is to use this kind of deep learning algorithm
to uh to create a design Loop basically where
we can uh find the sort of a sweet spot in terms
of the the material M um the micromorphometric
let's say uh you're interested in designing a
material that has certain Desir properties and
perform performance characteristics and what we
are able to do is to create uh digital specimens
or digital twins of the materials uh using a
deep bake algorithm so this is a generative AI um
traditionally we used the generative adversarial
neural networks but nowadays we're exploring also
diffusion modeling uh but this is basically
a deep fake algorithm that can synthesize um
synthetic micr structures uh you know and then
by using the synthetic micr structures what we
are able to do is to uh rapidly estimate the
the physical performance of the material using
the algorithm like Park and then you know
by comparing the predicted performance with
the design specification uh we can you know have
this kind of a design Loop where uh you know our
our algorithm is basically modifying this um this
this digital Twain uh and the you know the design
parameter of the material specimen uh until we get
to reach the performance characteristics that uh
uh we're we're looking to achieve So speaking of
um of deep fake uh here's a little bit of overview
of our previous work uh where we developed
this generative adversarial Network that uh
takes in certain numerical parameters to control
control the uh the morphometric characteristics of
the synthetic micr structure so it can not only
generate some realistic micr structure specimen
but also it can control uh the properties of those
specimen so as you can see in this example uh we
can change the orientation of the micro of the
crystals we can also change the size distribution
of the crystals uh and so on and so forth now
uh I would like to kind of deep you know take
take a deeper dive into this physics aware machine
learning um learning business because you know at
the very core of this you know this Grand Vision
is this idea of machine learning algorithm aware
of physics so what is physics aware versus physics
naive uh in other words why can I not just use uh
you know any other deep learning algorithm to you
know perform the same task so I think think the
problem in the physics Community here in adapting
um you know deep learning and all this you know
progress in machine learning is that the outputs
of machine learning algorithms are not guaranteed
to follow certain you know certain physical rules
uh so for example in traditional mechanics we all
know that uh you know moving objects will follow
this you know rule defined by Newton ethicals to
ma uh but you know if you just throw in data
and then you know pray for your neural network
to learn something about this relationship that
then the chance is you know the the actual output
of the neural network will not necessarily follow
this strict relationship called f equals to Ma so
uh we're kind of seeing a similar situation over
here uh when it comes to the material physics as
well uh there are certain governing rules and
uh Dynamics but if you just train a deep neural
network to learn that relationship then uh the
chance is it'll not be able to uh learn that
very well so as a matter of fact we compared our
our algorithm Park against other uh physics naive
algorithms so one uh kind of you know point of
comparison was unet uh which is you know very
widely used in a variety of different applications
and then here we have this algorithm called the
imagin Ator uh which is a very famous video
generation algorithm uh in the computer vision
community so none of these two are physically
aware and as a result of that uh first of all
we can see that the you know the growth rate of
hotspot is not necessarily um you know accurate
compared to the ground truth result and then also
interesting the in case of imaginator especially U
as you look at this part over here the Dynamics is
not continuous so uh the physics naive algorithms
doesn't necessarily know this continuous evolution
of the temperature field uh and then the the
growth of hotspots uh we could see that a lot of
this prediction result was kind of a um you know
fluctuating uh and sort of discontinuous in terms
of how you know how the hotpots grow and how hot
spots you know appear and disappear in order to uh
further validate the physics awareness of Park uh
we also kind of tested the algorithm on the time
steps that are not that were not included in the
in the in the training data set so here what we
were seeing is the prediction result uh of Park
up to uh 27 nond um that sounds like a very small
number but uh in the Dynamics of detonation that's
actually you know uh fairly long time step uh
and park was trained initially to predict up to
15 nond time interval and then up to that point uh
it did a pretty good job and then we were curious
you know uh if Park would be able to predict
the the Dynamics and the evolution of hotspots
Beyond these 15 NS and then uh we could see that
um you know it followed the general trend of the
hotspot evolution uh quite well not only for this
particular micr structure but also a variety of
other micr structures and as a matter of fact
uh the plot was um I mean the the quantitative
validation was also uh indicated that uh the
predicted uh result beyond the simulation time
was uh pretty accurate compared to the ground
truth except for the absolute temperature value
so interestingly earlier I I I mentioned that
it was about 500 Kelvin sort of underestimated
in case of Park but then as we go beyond um you
know 15 nond you can see this kind of you know
the trend kind of flips now you know Park sort of
overestimate the temperature so other than that
um we are generally happy with the result of Park
prediction and then I think this is indicative of
uh the physics awareness of uh AR architecture
now uh I think uh many of you uh I mean even
in biomedical engineering um many of you I think
will be familiar with this um recent um line of
work called a physics informed neural network
or pin uh and for those of you who are already
familiar with pen I think um it is um it is right
to sort of compare pin and park and how they are
different in terms of learning the physics so um
you know in machine learning um there are roughly
three different you know ways of learning physics
from data uh the first thing is observational bias
approach and observational bias approach is um in
some sense the most physics naive approach where
uh you just hope the machine learning algorithm to
learn some physical rules from the data itself and
then there's no other intervention uh commit into
play so uh that is probably the simplest um you
know approach but yet I think the most physics
naive approach uh which you know I don't think
is going to be very effective I think um the
the recent physics and form machine learning
um research is uh primarily in the direction of
this learning bias approach where the idea is uh
the physics governing equation is basically used
as a training loss in the back propagation process
and as a result of that uh the pde residual
is um is basically used to update the neural
network parameters so that you know the neural
network prediction not only you know minimize
the the data error the prediction error but also
the residual of the governing physics uh is kind
of the learning bias approach whereas um another
sort of approach that you can think of is what
is called the inductive bias approach and this is
basically this is basically Park so in inductive
bias approach what we're hoping to achieve is to
design a specific neural network architecture that
inherently embed the physics rules and principle
in the architecture itself so the differentiator
integrator architecture that I presented in part
is a good example of that inductive bias approach
now um in order to compare pen and park uh here's
a little toy problem called the burgers equation
this is um probably one of the simplest um fluid
dynamics equation uh that is popularly used in
comput computational fluid dynamics Community
uh for validation um of an algorithm so I'm not
going to go into the the niggr details of the the
the actual physical meanings of this but uh the
idea is given this governing equation can pin and
park uh learn this uh this fluid dnamic phenomena
and this is kind of the result of uh testing that
hypothesis so here's the ground truth initially
we have a gaan distribution of uh of this fluid
and then uh according to that Burger's equation
uh I mean the Dynamics governed by the burgers
equation you can see this fluid sort of moving
toward the right bottom corner and then we
have uh the an algorithm called the physics
cret which is basically a variant of one of the
the most recent variant of pin and then here we
have a park algorithm and as you can see uh
Park uh does a fairly good job of U you know
predicting the ground truth um you know uh fluid
dnamic Behavior Uh defined by the burgers equation
whereas the physics crnet seem to have a little
bit of um you know this jigglin or the the uh
what should I call this the this um uh grid like
artifacts uh in the prediction result but uh I
think overall um in terms of the performance
prediction performance I think both uh Park
and are um are quite good now um when we further
validate in investigated the the prediction error
and the solution quality uh we could actually see
that the result of Park sorry I forgot to include
the legend but the dashed line over here is the
result coming from Park and then the solid line
is the result coming from pin and then uh we're
plotting the error in a log scale uh so the the
top row is the prediction error so this is the
the data loss and then the bottom row is the
residual of the governing physics so uh again how
you know far off the prediction result from the uh
the physics defined by the burgers equation is
plotted at the bottom and then in general Park
seems to perform better than uh the pin all them
and then you know as you can see over here uh we
plotted this um um this scatter plot where the
horizontal axis is the PD residual and then the
vertical axis is the prediction error and then the
the red dots over here uh is the result from Park
uh which is um overall more accurate in you know
not only in prediction eror but also in the PD
residual and then we have this physics CR that
result where um it is a little bit off uh from
this um you know why goes to x uh line over here
so uh that is also sort of indicative of the fact
that Park is indeed uh physics aware um you know
compared to other physics and form neural network
algorithms now I think um what is most exciting
about Park and especially in the relation to
biomedical applications is that what if you don't
know the governing equation so like in case of
the burgers equation example uh we already had
this governing equation analytically defined so
we knew everything about the Dynamics and then
the challenge was basically about how well we
can approximate that readily known governing
equation but I suspect in a lot of problems in
bedal uh applications um we don't really know the
the governing equation defining the Dynamics of
biological systems at least we only know you know
partially uh what the Dynamics look like so for
those kind of situations uh can we still learn
and discover the governing equation is kind of
the uh reasonable question to ask and my answer to
that is yes uh we are actually uh able to discover
that uh the the energetic material example is
actually an archetype of uh such problem where
we don't fully know the governing equation of
the material system so in case of Park uh this
is learned uh from without knowing uh the actual
governing equation and then same thing over here
in case of pin again we train the algorithm
without actually telling uh what the governing
equation is because we don't have the the full set
of governing equations uh for for for this problem
and as you can see over here uh Park is still able
to um you know predict the hotspot Dynamics uh
despite the fact that we didn't know the governing
equation um you know in an analytical form so I
you know again I cannot think of a very specific
biomedical application but hopefully from uh from
this result uh you'll be able to um you know
connect the dots between uh what I'm you know
telling over here in the material uh example uh
with um the the research topic that you might be
interested in so uh for the interest of time uh
let me uh just move a little bit um so um uh you
another thing that I want to you know present over
here is you know along the line of discovery of
uh physics governing equations um I think uh the
the the issues with deep learning and deep neural
network models is that they're you know kind of a
blackbox and it's you know hard to interpret and
um what my group is working on currently is to
basically to open up this black box and see if
we can find features that are actually useful in
describing the Dynamics uh over here so uh one
such example here is uh what is called a salian
map I I think a lot of people are uh here in the
audience are familiar with this um techniques
called grad cam or ceny map techniques and and
things like that those are you know one of the uh
most you know widely used uh machine learning VI
I mean deep learning visualization algorithms um
to reveal uh the the reasoning process of uh deep
neural network prediction so long story short
uh what saliency map does does is to visualize
uh where this hot temperature regions comes from
so in other words what was the reason that the
neural network believed that there was going to be
a hot you know high temperature region and then we
can uh uh we can use a back propagation algorithm
to sort of track down uh what were the causes of
those high temperature regions in the prediction
result and this is kind of overlay of uh those you
know uh the track down result where we highlighted
the image regions in the the input micr structure
image uh that the neural network believes to have
you know led to the formation of hotspots and then
uh what's really interesting to me here is that
um you know even before all this deep learning
business the energetic material Community has
empirically discovered that the the cracks and
voids uh are actually the the main players in
the detonation of uh energetic materials so uh
one thing that was um pretty interesting to me
was that uh uh you know all this sanap result
highlighted the voids and cracks in the material
micr structures not the crystals themselves so
that I think is u um you know indicative of the
fact that you know Park was actually able to to
to learn the Dynamics uh in a physically you
know meaningful fashion uh as opposed to some
random combination of features but also uh another
interesting thing was so we we sort of um you know
plotted the saliency map and then some voys were
highlighted and some voys were not highlighted so
um you know which meant that some of the boys were
critical in the formation of the hot spots and
then some voids were not you know super critical
in for in the formation of hot spots so we've kind
of gathered those um what we call critical voids
and non-critical voids so critical voids are the
ones that are highlighted by the saliency map
and then non-critical voids are the ones that
are not highlighted by the saliency map and then
we sort of compare them uh to see if there's any
meaningful difference um and surprisingly I
mean even from the you know the glance of the
Void geometry even with the Naked Eyes we can see
that there's some difference between the critical
voids and the non-critical void I think the most
you know prominent thing is that there's a certain
size distribution of the C critical voids whereas
non-critical voids are just like everywhere in
terms of the size and then also you can see that
the CR critical voids are sort of you know uh sort
of lying flat whereas uh non-critical voids have
all kind of different orientations you know some
are vertical some are slanted uh and so on and so
forth and when we quantitatively compare the two
uh we could actually find some statistically
meaningful Trends between critical voids and
non-critical voids so right now we're uh we're
actually working with um you know more theoretical
U people um trying to understand the physic of
energetic material um you know Dynamics and then
we're also working with um uh the computational
modeling people um to kind of distill um a new
set of Knowledge from the result learned by a
deep neural network algorithm and that's kind
of you know uh one of the ways that an AI could
be useful for scientific discovery um not only
in Material Science but I think in uh biomedical
applications uh I think you would be able to find
those kind of applications very well so um that
so far has been the ongoing research and before
I conclude I'll um mention briefly some of the the
future directions that we're currently working on
um one of the let me let me just skip this slide
one of the critical limitations of the first the
earliest version of Park uh was the fact that it
was only for diffusion dominant uh phenomenon so
uh we actually you know had to normalize the
evolution of the temperature field so that we
can get rid of all the advection phenomena and um
you know as a result of that uh for unnormalized
data so for the data that contains the advection
terms uh you can see the park versin one doesn't
do a very good job in U predicting the dynamic
so in order to overcome that uh we recently um
developed this new version of Park where we can
now consider the advection and reaction terms
on top of the diffusion dominant phenomena so uh
we have this momentum equation over here and the
energy equation uh and then by including those two
uh we were able to achieve a lot better prediction
result uh as you can see over here so on the top
row we have the ground proof and then Park version
one you can see that it only kind of captures the
the the overall growth uh of the pattern but it
doesn't really capture this you know like swirly
shapes uh as a result of the ection whereas Park
verion two seems to be seems to be doing a much
better job in detecting those and then another
thing is um we also wanted to um you know vary
the operating condition of the parks so again the
initial uh Park paper only contained the result
of uh a very particular um shock loading condition
which was 9.5 gigap pasal and then uh the initial
version of Park uh wasn't able to generalize to
other operating conditions so the idea that we
also explored is uh this idea of style Vector
in generative adversarial networks where basically
we uh intentionally biasing the prediction result
based off of some scalar parameters so using
this idea what we were able to do is to bias
the prediction results so 9.5 gigap Pascal is
what uh you know Park was originally trained
for and then here's a you know weaker shock
loading and as a result of that uh if you look
at the Grand truth we have a lot lesser you know
hot spots uh you know formed as a result of that
shock and then uh Park uh without having to add a
lot more data uh we were able to uh make a pretty
good prediction of that uh phenomena uh by using
this style Vector idea uh and then same thing goes
with the you know much stronger shock here where
uh instead of 9.5 gigap Pascal now we have 15 GPA
and then uh as you can see Park uh again without
having to you know add a lot more data we have a
pretty good you know prediction result over here
so these are kind of the the ongoing uh direction
of research uh with that I think for the interest
of time I'll I'll just stop here and then in case
that you you know there's any question from the
audience I'll be happy to answer those thank you
Ste Steve thank you so much this was really really
cool I really really like this and from the point
point of view of like biophysical systems where
things like this might be handy I would imagine
things like you know just like even if it's
like outside of the physical body but like an
epidemiological application you know how a virus
might spread through a number of individuals for
example there's a famous example called Fishers
equation which is uh sort of the propagation of
a an Al with a particular frequency spreading
through a population and so population genetics
folks look at models like that there's also like
metabolic processes or gene expression where genes
are being you know kind of activated in a system
um uh with a relative to a pte um motor responses
from muscle fibers and how those uh respond in a
jointed system like an arm or a leg or something
like that and then of course stuff that I really
like is uh you know neural Action potentials um
like hodkin Huxley models which are also
uh partial differential equations and so
there's all manner of different pdes that exist in
biophysics and Physiology and uh you know various
other systems that these kind of things would be
very appropriate for I agree age have you explored
any of those no no not at the moment so right now
uh my group is pretty busy with uh you know a few
of the grants from the Department of Defense and
the National Science Foundation um highly focused
on Material Science research but we were actually
kind of exploring um you know how we can kind of
expand our you know Horizon and then you know
find different applications and then biomedical
obviously was one of the one of the direction that
we were hoping to um you know move forward to but
um not nothing you know very specific or you know
Tang at the moment so I'll be open to you know
ideas and suggestions from the audience or even
like uh you know if there's anybody interested
in collaborating I'll be interested in exploring
those uh those ideas one of the things which I
think was particularly interesting is that you
mentioned that you know ordinarily solving some
of these models you know requires between 16
and 30 hours on a high performance Computing
system and with some of these models you get a
pretty good guess at least an initial guess when
in under a second using commodity hardware and
I'm kind of just curious if when you then take
these methods and you put them on a supercomputer
you know you should one probably get a very high
fidelity answer in you know no hardly any time at
all certainly better than 16 to 30 hours have you
done that and do you are you able to to see those
kind of performance improvements so that that's a
great question Jack and um frankly that was the
initial kind of motivation behind this research
we wanted to come up with a good initial estimate
of the solution so that we can you know like uh
accelerate the the simulation so the idea is
basically to you know make a a rapid guess of
the initial solution using Park and then using
that as an input now the the more rigorous you
know physics code should be able to converge to
a rigorous solution in much faster speed was the
initial idea but then we sort of came to this
I don't know um not not a conclusion but we we
came to this thought that maybe that's um sort of
an Overkill uh when it comes to this particular
application because uh one you know current
missing block right now is that we haven't
validated this on an actual physical experiments
and and uh the simulation model I mean simulation
uh model is also just a you know a numerical uh
characterization of some you know actual physics
and then um I mean in the simulation Community
there's a saying that um you know no models are
are accurate but some models are useful right
so uh all models are basically wrong so there
there's certain you know discrepancy between the
real physics versus what the simulation captures
so given that um like do we even want to um
you know achieve that incremental Improvement
you know of the park prediction when you know the
the simulation will anyways give us some you know
erronous results so if that is going to be the
case why don't we just use this as is and then
you know try to use it for you know something more
useful was kind of the you know the the flow of
thoughts but but yeah I mean like your your idea
of using part uh as an initial condition for a
simulation solver is is perfectly valid and then
there there are as a matter effect uh people you
know trying to use neural networks to boost the
solution process of partial differential equations
so that's perfectly um you know uh useful idea
that uh already a lot of people are exploring one
other thing is the um does Park actually return
to you a a solution to the not a solution to the
equation but actually what the governing equation
happens to be so I mean what the examples you
show look like they're you know producing a result
which emulates the underly you the physical thing
that you're trying to do but does it actually
spit back a thing saying you know oh Dell two
of some process is equal to the you know basically
it's that equation but like for example what if if
if it were the wave equation would it be able to
return the form of the of the wave equation for
example so that that is a wonderful question and
that is in fact uh a research problem of one of my
posts so right now I think the current limitation
of the you know this whole physics and form
machine learning research not only Park but also
you know many other um you know machine learning
approaches I think their limitation is that uh
we're just giving a parametric approximation of
that unknown you know governing equation sure
and we only you know approximate the optimal
configuration of theta uh that defines the neural
network we don't really return the actual ordinary
differential sorry actual governing equation terms
so uh there is a line of research in this area
where people are trying to figure out you know
what what is the functional form instead of like
this huge humongous set of numerical values that
defines you know the neural network weights uh
what are the actual you know meaningful uh physics
governing equation that are human interpretable
is kind of you know one of the direction that um
you know people are um heading into and my group
is kind of you know working on the same you know
sort of a problem which is why you know the sany
map result that I presented um in the the later
part of this you know presentation is also to
sort of you know open up this black box and then
try to you know uh distill uh you know more useful
form of equation as opposed to a collection of
you know millions of neural network parameters
so that is kind of uh you know really interesting
uh research question for the future yeah I really
appreciate that because as you know as you know
you get out these neural networks they have a
gajillion number of hidden layers and all the
connections between them and it basically it's
not the kind of it's not very compact right you
couldn't like go and say oh here's the schinger
equation or here's the you know the the the the
heat equation which would be you know those are
the basis for a lot of different physical models
um or D derivations thereof and you know we have
this very complicated data it would be nice to be
able to compr you know solve them but then be able
to show and here's the canonical form of this as
an actual pte because some of the parameters of
those pdes are very important to understanding the
Dynamics of those systems and I'm thinking of like
speed and and Signal say transduction velocity
or wavefront velocity um which give you a lot of
information about the Dynamics of these systems
and you described that a little bit in one of
your earlier examples um but you know having it
in that final form would be very very handy so
that's right that's right so like going back to
this slide I mean you know at the current stage
we're not able to give this you know specific form
of equation here but we can uh predict the force
uh for example very well with some blackbox you
know machine learning algorithm that takes you
know the mass and the distance as an input but
yeah currently we're unable to tell this you know
very specific form of equation so well I it sounds
like you are well on your way Steve so uh we're at
the top of the hour so I want to thank you again
Steve for uh really giving us an inspiring talk
because this is really this is really cool stuff
because it really F you know puts a foundation
onto some of these blackbox neural network
approaches that you know they give us an answer
that looks great but it doesn't have any you know
like you sort of said we sort of trust that these
things may have some bearing in reality and it
would be actually nice to have them you know
physically informed so that we can actually put
some more trust in them so thank you for sharing
this great work and thank you for giving us a
lot to think about uh and so thank you again
and thanks to everybody who joined us and have
a wonderful weekend absolutely thank you so much